die nachrichten des tages heute mitglied
der jury ihnen allen einen schönen guten
abend sportlich ist jede menge los
christen wir gucken nach münchen
european championships grünamt wir
verschaffen uns jetzt erstmal einen
gemeinsamen überblick
lindners umstrittene steuer pläne
angesichts der hohen inflation will der
finanzminister steuertarife verschieben
und die kalte progression bekämpfen
strom gegen gas weil frankreichs
atomkraftwerke derzeit schwächeln
importiert das land deutschen strom und
will dafür im winter erdgas liefern
einer von uns nur besser mit einer
bewegenden trauerfeier verabschieden
sich hamburg und fußball-deutschland von
uwe seeler
in deutschland bekommt man seit monaten
weniger für sein geld die teuerungsrate
hat sich im juli zwar leicht
abgeschwächt liegt aktuell aber immer
noch bei 7,5 prozent
insofern wurde heute morgen mit spannung
der auftritt von finanzminister lindner
erwartet der seine steuererleichterung
pläne präsentierte
kernpunkt ist ein ausgleich für die
sogenannte kalte progression wir wollen
uns das jetzt noch mal genau anschauen
in deutschland entscheidet sich das hand
an hand des einkommens wie viel steuern
jemand zahlen muss steigt das einkommen
dann steigt auch der steuersatz durch
die inflation kann es dann dazu kommen
dass trotz mehr geld real sogar weniger
gehalt im portemonnaie ankommt was
christian lindner dagegen tun will
britta buchholz
der minister bittet die journalistin
ausnahmsweise in den garten des
bundesfinanzministeriums eine neue
kulisse für seine idee lindner will das
steuersystem an die inflation anpassen
es geht um rund 10 milliarden euro
hier geht es darum eine sonst heimliche
steuererhöhungen abzuwenden
hier geht es nicht um entlastung es geht
um verzicht auf belastung die sogenannte
kalte progression müsse dringender denn
je abgefedert werden sein konzept die
verschiebung der steuertarife so soll
der grundfreibetrag steigen also das
einkommen bis zu dem keine steuern zeit
werden müssen auch der spitzensteuersatz
soll er später greifen kern des modells
die steuertarife werden nach rechts
verschoben aus der spd kommt kritik aber
man zeigt sich gesprächsbereit
das ist richtig dass er das getan hat
das ja auch zeigt wir wollen jetzt
ordentlich geld in die hand nehmen ich
sage aber auch ganz klar für uns als spd
der fokus muss bei denjenigen liegen die
kleine mittlere einkommen haben die
wirklich hart von dieser krise betroffen
sind und da werden wir jetzt im detail
mit dem finanzminister darüber reden das
geplante modell entlastet prozentual
geringverdiener deutlich stärker als
topverdiener in absoluten zahlen sieht
das so aus ein bürger mit einem zu
versteuernden einkommen von 20.000 euro
würde im kommenden jahr 115 euro weniger
steuern zahlen bei einem einkommen von
60.000 euro wären es 471 euro für noch
höhere einkommen sind es maximal
479 euro angedacht außerdem das
kindergeld soll bei den ersten beiden
kindern ab 20 23 um acht euro pro monat
steigen für das dritte kind um zwei euro
der kinderfreibetrag soll schrittweise
erhöht werden doch kritiker fordern
direkte entlastung für
einkommensschwache in ihrer kritik sind
sich koalitionspartner grüne und linke
opposition einig der vorschlag der den
herr lindner gemacht hat der hat eine
richtung und die heißt je mehr ich
verdiene umso mehr wird am ende des
jahres auch bei mir ankommen und das ist
aus unserer sicht nicht gerecht es ist
ein unseriöses angebot mit dem die
menschen auch über den tisch gezogen
werden denn 70 prozent der bevölkerung
werden von diesen sogenannten entlastung
gar nichts oder nur sehr wenig haben
lindner sagt 48 millionen bürger würden
durch sein konzept bei der steuer
entlastet wie die ampel eine linie
finden soll bei dieser frage das
beantwortet er allerdings nicht
zur einschätzung gehen wir nach berlin
zu theo koll theo die steuerpläne
kritisiert nicht nur die opposition auf
die regierungspartner haben einwände wie
viel wird am ende von den plänen übrig
bleiben also ich glaube vieles von den
plänen dürfte erhalten bleiben denn
angesichts der enormen inflation scheint
es zwingend den bürgern keine
belastungen dadurch aufzubürden dass sie
inflationsbedingt sind höhere
steuerklasse rutschen und lindner hat
ein kleines ampel internes
friedensangebot eingebaut in dem er den
topverdienern die entlastung gestrichen
hat die wesentliche diskussion aber
dürfte sein mit welchen maßnahmen
weitergehen entlastet werden kann die
einkommensteuer ist ja das eine aber ein
erheblicher teil der belastung kommt
über indirekte steuern das heißt
beispielsweise wird die mehrwertsteuer
und die belastet bei weiter steigenden
preise preisen ja alle vor allem aber
geringverdiener und ab oktober kommt
dann auch noch die gasanlage oben drauf
also der ampel stehen da hitzige
diskussionen bevor sollen die enorm
gestiegenen gewinne der energiekonzerne
durch eine über gewinn steuer umverteilt
werden und soll die schuldenbremse
wirklich wieder eingehalten werden oder
wie weiter mit dem neuen euro ticket
oder mit den akw s die tabu zonen aller
ampel partner sind mittlerweile ziemlich
verletzt und demzufolge
glaube ich dürften die rempeleien euro
werden danke für die einordnung theo
koll nach berlin
wir stecken mittendrin in der größten
energie krise seit jahrzehnten aber
einer der sonst sichersten
stromlieferanten für deutschland muss
ausgerechnet jetzt blank ziehen nämlich
frankreich das land mit 56 atomreaktoren
kann gerade nicht einmal den eigenen
bedarf decken denn wegen überfälligen
wartungsarbeiten sind nur 27 davon in
betrieb jetzt brauchen die franzosen
strom aus deutschland zumal die extreme
dürre bei ihnen den akw noch schwerer
macht thomas weiter dazu
hitze und trockenheit haben die garonne
in südwestfrankreich auf 28 grad
gebracht ein problem für das
atomkraftwerk in gold fest dass mit dem
was er aus der garonne gekühlt wird es
leitet wärmeres wasser zurück als
normalerweise erlaubt umweltschützer
kritisieren das
wasser das mit mehr als 30 grad zurück
geleitet wird kann weniger sauerstoff
aufnehmen dabei brauchen die fische
genau wie wir sauerstoff
fünf atomkraftwerke in frankreich haben
ausnahmegenehmigungen bekommen um trotz
hitze und niedriger wasserstände der
flüsse wenigstens etwas strom liefern zu
können sie werden dringend gebraucht
wegen korrosionsschäden und
wartungsarbeiten steht die hälfte der
französischen
wie derzeit still
man erklärt den franzosen nicht
hinreichend was da im winter auf sie
zukommen wird man pflegt immer noch den
mythos der atomkraft die frankreich
retten werde
die regierung hat angekündigt 14 neue
meiler bauen zu lassen doch kurzfristig
muss sie eine lücke schließen statt wie
sonst fast 70 prozent liefert atomkraft
derzeit nur 58 prozent der energie statt
strom zu exportieren importiert
frankreich derzeit strom auch aus
deutschland wir wollen die wirtschaft
schützen wir wollen dass deutschland in
der lage ist uns strom zu liefern wenn
wir ihn brauchen und wie im gegenzug gas
wenn sie es brauchen
frankreich verweist darauf dass es mit
seinen flüssiggasterminals deutschland
beliefern könne französisches gas gegen
deutschen strom damit dass dauerhaft
funktioniert vor den die franzosen die
deutschen auf ihre atomkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen
auch spanien will energiesparen seit
heute gilt dort ein umfassender plan um
europas abhängigkeit von russischem gas
zu verringern öffentliche gebäude aber
auch geschäftsräume hotels und bahnhöfe
dürfen nur noch auf 27 grad
heruntergekühlt werden für bars und
restaurants gelten 25 grad im winter
dürfen die innenräume nur noch auf
maximal 19 grad beheizt werden und nach
22 uhr heißt es für schaufenster leere
büros und denkmäler licht aus
mehrere explosionen erschütterten
gestern eine russische militärbasis auf
der annektierten halbinsel krim
daraufhin wurde im gebiet der notstand
ausgerufen und jetzt steht die frage im
raum war es ein angriff moskau sagt nein
spricht von einem unfall der ukrainische
präsident selent ski bleibt vage
erklärte in seiner videoansprache der
russische krieg habe mit der krim
begonnen und werde mit ihr enden mit der
befreiung es wäre die erste militärische
attacke auf ziele auf der krim gut 200
kilometer hinter der frontlinie
ein jahr nach der machtübernahme der
taliban in afghanistan haben die
islamisten viele fortschritte im bereich
bildung oder gleichberechtigung wieder
zurückgedreht für eine reportage haben
kathrin eigen von sebastian eben unter
anderem junge mädchen und frauen
getroffen für die sich die situation
durch die taliban radikal verändert hat
wie das zeigt jetzt ihr bericht
wir sind in einer untergrund schule
irgendwo in afghanistan
wo genau können wir nicht sagen zu
gefährlich die taliban drohen mit
drakonischen strafen
dieser unterricht ist in afghanistan
verboten mädchen ab der sechsten klasse
dürfen laut den taliban nicht mehr zur
schule gehen
die 17 jährige sarah ist trotzdem hier
sie möchte unbedingt ärztin werden
warum dürfen wir unsere schule nicht
fertig machen was ist der unterschied
zwischen mädchen und jungen
in china ist selbst erst 17 bis vor
kurzem ging sie noch zur schule jetzt
ist sie die lehrerin und hat alles aus
dem nichts aufgebaut ein klassenraum für
50 schülerinnen und schüler bücher
organisiert an den lehrplan erstellt
sie selbst macht das alles freiwillig
verdient kein geld
alle wollen hier englisch lernen um ins
ausland zu gehen danach wollen sie
wieder zurückkommen nach afghanistan um
unser land in frieden wieder aufzubauen
das schulverbot für mädchen ist in
afghanistan selbst unter den taliban
umstritten
im zdf interview gibt das tool
ministerium ein versprechen ab
mädchenschulen bis zur sechsten klasse
sind geöffnet genauso wie universitäten
es ist nicht möglich dass man von der
sechsten klasse direkt im juni geht
deswegen werden wir die schulen auch für
ältere mädchen öffnen
versprechungen die die taliban schon
lange machen hier in der untergrund
schule glauben sie daran nicht und so
leitete china weiter den verbotenen
unterricht sechs stunden lang jeden tag
die reportage afghanistan hinter dem
schleier die gibt es heute abend um 22
15 uhr im zdf oder schon jetzt in
unserer art mediathek
für rund zweieinhalb millionen
schülerinnen und schüler in nordrhein
westfalen ging es heute wieder zurück
zur schule begonnen haben damit auch
wieder diskussionen über den corona
schutz mit oder ohne maske mit oder ohne
tests flächendeckende schulschließungen
jedenfalls hat bildungsministerin stark
watzinger ausgeschlossen über den start
in das neue schuljahr jetzt peter böhme
schulstart in nrw die
werner-von-siemens-realschule in
düsseldorf auf dem stundenplan auch der
7a heute als erstes testen aber ohne
zwang
bei den tests macht dann aber nur ein
drittel der klasse mit aber das testen
habe ich nicht weil
ich mich fast jedes wochenende auch
texte zu hause ich wollte halt einfach
nur bis nach den ferien habe ich mich
irgendwo angesteckt habe und wenn ja
möchte ich halt nicht meine
klassenkameraden anstecken ich habe mich
in den sommerferien echt oft getestet
und es wäre mir jetzt heute zu viel
eigenverantwortung alles freiwillig in
nrw die maske tragen sie dann aber doch
alle jeder schüler bekommt pro monat
fünf tests für daheim mit wenn er sich
denn bei symptomen testen will der
klassenlehrerin wären aber generell
klare vorgaben lieber ich persönlich
würde mir eine verbindlichkeit und eine
klare regelung wünschen im sinne der
kinder ich finde es ist für kinder eine
schwierige entscheidung selbst zu
überlegen teste ich mich jetzt oder
nicht warum sollte ich es machen warum
auch nicht die anderen gucken mich an
masken pflicht kann nur angeordnet
werden wenn bei hohen inzidenz der
präsenzunterricht gefährdet wäre denn
oberste devise in bund und ländern die
schulen sollen offen bleiben eine
herausfordernde situation für die
lehrerkollegien wenn fünf sechs kollegen
erkranken ist eben für die anderen
kolleginnen und kollegen schon ein
enormes und ein enormer mehraufwand dar
es zerreißt den plan
differenzierungs strenge geraten
durcheinander
ja und ja 78 19 haben wir auch schon
aufgefangen aber irgendwann ist dann
schluss coruna im dritten jahr im winter
werden sie wieder lüften sagt der
schulleiter
im südwesten frankreichs hatten zwei
große brände die menschen schon
wochenlang in atem gehalten einer der
beiden flammt gerade wieder dramatisch
auf im waldgebiet südlich von bordeaux
sind gleich drei gemeinden in gefahr
fast 4000 menschen mussten sich schon in
sicherheit bringen 16 häuser brannten
eine neue hitzewelle erschwert die
löscharbeiten bis sonntag soll es in der
gegend temperaturen um die 40 grad geben
heute hieß es abschied nehmen von einem
ganz großen der weit über den fußball
hinaus strahlt nämlich stürmer legende
uwe seeler über jahrzehnte spielte er
für seinen verein den hsv wurde
vereinspräsident und hamburger
ehrenbürger
unvergessen auch seelers einsätze in der
nationalmannschaft
ende juli war uns uwe im alter von 5 80
jahren gestorben in hamburg sagte man
heute im iran berichtet wie oft wurde
uwe seeler hier frenetisch bejubelt
heute am tag des abschieds stille auf
den rängen im volksparkstadion
star pianist joja wendt und der
hamburger seemanns chor eröffnete die
trauerfeier mit der hamburg hymne
harmonia
[Musik]
unter den trauerrednern dfb präsident
bernd neuendorf er würdigte vor allem
uwe seelers besondere persönlichkeit uwe
seeler hat im trikot der
nationalmannschaft
keinen einzigen großen titel gewonnen
aber
die wahrheit ist uwe seeler brauchte
eben auch keinen titel um zu einem idol
zu werden auf wunsch von uwe seelers
ehefrau eva kiltz schauspieler olli
dittrich ein langjähriger freund der
familie die abschlussrede als ich von
seinem tod erfuhr hatte ich für einen
kurzen moment wieder dieses gefühl wie
2014 als meine eltern kurz nacheinander
verstorben waren es war dieser gedanke
jetzt bist du allein unter den rund 5000
gästen befand sich viel prominenz aus
sport unterhaltung und politik auch
bundeskanzler olaf scholz nahm an der
trauerfeier teil hier in seiner heimat
bleibt uwe seeler unvergessen als
herausragender sportler als hamburger
als mensch
aus der heimat von uns uwe 790 kilometer
weiter südlich nach münchen und dort das
nächste sportliche großereignis klein
mega event zum zweiten mal vier jahre
nach der gelungenen premiere in glasgow
in berlin ist nun die bayerische
landeshauptstadt münchen austragungsort
der european championships genau 50
jahre nach den olympischen sommerspielen
72 an selber stelle
back to the roots also zurück zu den
dächern heißt es in münchen wo in den
kommenden elf tagen ein hauch von mini
olympia wien wird 4700 athletinnen und
athleten aus ganz europa suchen einen
neuen sportarten ihre besten auch für ex
fußballer und musiker materia der bei
der eröffnungsfeier sind ein besonderes
ereignis ich finde es super ich finde es
schön dass
sportarten mal außerhalb des fußballs
gewürdigt werden so den letzten wochen
passport mehr getroffen deswegen freue
ich mich ein teil von trier beste gold
chancen hat aus deutscher sicht zum
beispiel sebastian brendel der erst
vergangene woche wieder kanu weltmeister
wurde und auch in münchen mit dem hacker
zu den großen favoriten zählt das wäre
natürlich auch weitspringerin malaika me
hamburg sie nach ihrer krone infektion
allerdings rechtzeitig fit wird ist noch
fraglich
münchen jedenfalls stünde bereit für
spitzenleistungen an historischer stätte
und stefan leifert steht mitten im
geschehen im olympiapark stefan was
erwartet münchen von diesen european
championships
für münchen ist dass hier gerade ein
ganz großer moment denn mit der
eröffnungsfeier in diesen minuten im
vollgepackten olympiapark gehen drei
jahre der vorbereitung zu ende münchen
und die veranstalter denken hier in ganz
großen bögen wollen anknüpfen an die
olympischen spiele von 1972 an diesen
geist der vor den attentaten hier
herrschte und wollen eine veranstaltung
ganz neuer art schaffen durch
nachhaltigkeit und durchschaubarkeit
nachhaltigkeit dadurch dass kein
einziger neubau hier nötig war die alten
sportstätten von 72 werden genutzt und
nahbar kite dadurch dass viele
sportstätten mitten in der münchner
innenstadt stattfinden beachvolleyball
zum beispiel dass die ticket preise
niedrig sind 10 20 euro teilweise schon
viele veranstaltungen sind sogar
kostenlos und trotzdem haben diese
european championships noch muss man
sagen ein mobilisierungsproblem viele
münchner haben noch gar nicht
mitbekommen was hier in den nächsten elf
tagen stattfinden wird viele tickets
sind noch nicht abgerufen das soll sich
ab heute ändern so hoffen die
veranstalter deren ziel bleibt hier lust
zu schaffen auf sportereignisse die
dieser dimension und vielleicht sogar
lust zu machen auf eine und neue
deutsche olympia bewerbung in naher oder
mittlerer zukunft wir werden darüber
berichten wie vielen dank stefan also es
ist schon einiges los in münchen sie
können von 20 uhr an online unter
sportstudio de und in der zdf mediathek
live die eröffnungsfeier mit verfolgen
die fußball-wm der männer soll einen tag
früher beginnen bereits am 20 november
dadurch könnte wie seit 2006 üblich
gastgeber katar das eröffnungsspiel
bestreiten gegen ecuador noch ist nichts
entschieden aber es wird eine zustimmung
der fifa erwartet
knapp drei monate nach dem europa league
sieg will eintracht frankfurt am abend
gegen den gewinner der champions league
real madrid im uefa super cup
triumphieren die fans beider
mannschaften stimmen sich in helsinki
schon fröhlich ein mehr als 1000
anhänger aus frankfurt fiebern seit
mittag den anpfiff entgegen auch nicht
so fröhlich 21 uhr geht's los dürfte
spannend werden dankeschön christin wir
haben noch die zahlen vom mittwoch lotto
und die gehen so 10 18
22 24 26 27 und die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt zdf.de oder
auf der zf textseite 557 zum wetter
weiterhin viel zu trocken einzelheiten
gleich von präsident alan um 21 uhr 45
im heute-journal marietta slomka im
interview mit finanzminister lindner das
heute 19 team bedankt sich fürs
zuschauen und wünscht ihnen einen
entspannten abend morgen an dieser
stelle barbara häufig auch bald
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter extrem wenig regen bisher in
deutschland im mittel in diesem sommer
100 3 liter auf den quadratmeter gab es
seit anfang juni bis ende august geht ja
der meteorologische sommer ja und der
letzte rekord wäre der absolute rekord
lag bei 130 liter auf den quadratmeter
und der ist von jahr 2018 und es geht ja
trocken weiter wir haben es weiterhin
mit einem umfangreichen hoch zu tun
kräftige östliche strömung ja und dazu
dass hitze tief über spanien das macht
sich schon wieder bereit für die nächste
hitzewelle in der kommenden nacht
trocken und kräftiger wind im süden und
das bei temperaturen von neun grad an
den alpen und 18 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und morgen wieder viel
sonnenschein und wieder im süden vor
allem kräftiger ostwind teils über den
bergen auch stürmisch das lindert die
temperaturen die hits das hitze
empfinden denn die werte steigen im
südwesten auf 32 grad im westen auf 34
und an der ostsee auf 24 die kommenden
tage es geht heiß weiter bei 34 grad mit
gewittern am freitag ja und ab samstag
weiterhin trocken sonntag bis 35 grad
ein schöner ort